Tonight Show appearance but three Howie
Mandel 3D glasses on tonight's show
okay you have it oh there it is there it
is okay so that's
okay this is like at the beginning I'm
carrying the thing in my lap is my
handbag it's in the shape of a
handbag yeah so Jim McCauley was so
nervous you know because what I learned
is these Bookers almost have more at
stake than you do because even if you do
great if you do great Johnny goes up to
him and goes oh my God great booking Jim
yeah you did great if you die he goes up
to him and goes why the [ __ ] would you
book him so they were always trying to
second-guess the host the Bookers didn't
book what they liked they book what they
think most likes yes and not only and
only Johnny not necessarily the audience
because I kept saying well listen to the
audience the audience even if Johnny
doesn't like me can't I be on because
the audience laughs so he said listen
and then he started micromanaging I
don't know if he ever he he started
saying what's the set going to be and I
had to go over each question in every
word and which is really hard
for me especially what and also for you
because they're not jokes yeah there are
things that you talk about like even my
glove if somebody hadn't seen me I
remember I got thrown off at Dick Clark
Show because he goes we need a big
closing joke from you and I go well I'm
going to close with building glove on
your head he goes I haven't seen you son
what is the closing I said I'll put a
rubber GL I put a rubber surgical glove
on my head and I pop it off and the
audience loves it and he says why he
goes he goes why that's no we would need
a joke at the end yeah yeah we need a
joke that I swear to you it's a joke I
swear he goes I don't get the [ __ ]
joke you're gonna put a rubber glove on
your head and then it's gonna pop off
and why will they laugh and I said I
don't know but I do it don't yeah you
just know yeah you just know they
canceled me from that wow but but anyway
so he was going after like whatever
questions I asked whatever things and
we're gonna you know this is set up it
was all gonna be panel yeah it's all
going to be set up so then I said you
know what I'm here
I'm never gonna be here again
I didn't like the way the way he was
designing what I was doing didn't feel
uh solid to me didn't feel like it felt
like somebody [ __ ] with my own heart
yeah you know what I mean I know how I
want to do it and I know how I deliver
and I know what order it makes sense to
me and you're [ __ ] it up yeah so I'm
gonna do one thing just for me and if
this one thing for me doesn't work I go
down in flames and I got to do it I
still get to say I did The Tonight Show
so after I had done all my prepared
stuff yeah I said Johnny you wanna see
something and he goes yeah I go do you
like 3D movies and I could see out of it
he was at the end of the couch Jim and
call he's going what the I don't know
what this is
[ __ ] is he doing yeah so I pulled out
those stupid cardboard 3D glasses yeah
and I said put these on this is amazing
and he's going okay okay what is it and
this I I reached into my handbag yeah
and I pull out a little stuffed animal
yeah and I take it as hard as I can and
I whip it in his face oh my God oh my
God wait wait yeah wait wait wait wait
wait wait
you're not scared it might hurt him or
totally
nobody it's so brave or stupid it's kind
of but there is a thin line it is kind
of stupid though I would have done it
if I thought about it I wouldn't have
done it I made the decision and then I
don't go back on my decisions and I said
yes to myself okay and I didn't say no
so what happened so from the moment that
hit his face yeah well for the moment I
reached it in the bag and grabbed
whatever it was I was throwing to the
time I thought it in my mind I think you
can play it's on tape yeah yeah it it it
uh seemed like two hours
be like this bunny or whatever but I had
this and I would just say after it hit
him and he reacted he actually
kick the [ __ ] up the punch line
because he did the punch line he goes
this is amazing it was my punchline
doesn't it look like it's coming right
at you all right you know it was it was
just a joke but he fell off a seat
laughed so hard and that was the first
set I ended up doing 22 tonight shows
with Johnny I did them with I did them
with uh Gary Shandling and I did them
more with uh other guest hosts but I did
22 with him from that moment that you're
watching right now so that could have
gone down the toilet right now after
that gym right did he yell at you
afterwards or no no he thought it was
amazing I'll tell you I ended up losing
my time on the so after 22 Episodes put
up the picture of Howie Mandel on The
Tonight Show uh with uh tiger saber
tooth tiger is there a picture yeah yeah
there's got to be a picture
do you see it yeah there it is first top
left there click on that that's an
actual so what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay well I'll tell you about this okay
so this is the last time I did it with
Johnny okay wait wait what I see is a
carrot yeah yeah on top of a
saber-toothed tiger giant Sabertooth
yeah but it's like a fake one obviously
the carrot or the Tiger
okay all right
yeah okay so this is this is it's not it
doesn't start off funny but um I became
the Preferred Guest uh like any comic
anytime somebody was out they would call
me he trusted me I could do whatever I
want and this day
um Sammy Davis Jr was supposed to be the
lead guest on that day he got diagnosed
with cancer
at two o'clock in there at two o'clock
in the afternoon so Jim called me and
said you got to do what's the biggest
favor this is an hour before he says you
got to come down and fill in we don't
have a lead guest we just lost Sammy you
got to come on and I said to be honest
with you I'm at Laird Studios down in in
by the MGM there I'm doing a movie and
I'm off in now I'm just getting wrapped
but I have nothing I can't do it and he
goes please I beg you I beg you I said
you know you're begging me and you guys
have been good to me I've been there
like 30 times already I'll do it but on
one condition the condition is
I don't have time to go over material
I'm gonna
just rack my brain right now and
whenever I come up with you got to
accept me he goes I love you Howie I
love you you got to do that okay so I
walk into the I'm on at the studio and I
walk into the prop Department yeah and
in the prop Department there's this
giant saber-tooth tiger
and I said uh how much would it cost for
me to take that saber-toothed tiger just
for an hour put it on a dolly and
deliver it to Burbank Studios
and he goes I'll do that for 500 I go
you got it we're gonna do that and I
need it going now you got to put that on
a thing and then I just turned to my
right and there's a giant carrot on the
Shelf
and I said can you tie that carrot on
top of the Sabertooth Pike and he goes
for an extra hundred dollars I go that's
that's worth it yeah so I for six
hundred dollars he ties this carrot onto
the Sabretooth tiger onto that Dolly
yeah
I swear to God it was just random it's
kind of like you think yeah you know it
was just random I had no idea and I
delivered that to Burbank Jim calls me
and says what are you gonna do with it
and I said I don't know please Jim don't
you know yeah so what happened is I had
been on 30 times and I hear him
introducing me and they go ladies and
gentlemen Howie Mandel and uh the the
curtain opens and the audience is
applauding and I come out and I'm
pulling that saber-toothed tiger on the
dolly and I can hear the audience is
applauding I get to that where his desk
is is a riser yeah you know it's like
there's the main floor where the band is
and this is this whole thing the desk
and the couches are on a riser I get to
the Riser and the dolly stops at the
Riser yeah so now I turn around and I'm
trying to lift the head of the
Sabertooth tiger at the front the front
tires onto the onto the Riser yeah at
this time it's an eternity there's no
more Applause they're just waiting so so
then I say to doc doc can you give me a
hand doc puts down his trumpet and he
walks over and he's behind me I said
what do you want I said like push with
push and then I called Ed McMahon I said
lift it's an eternity probably three
minutes but three minutes of television
yeah
death not only that at that time the way
they have their cameras set the cameras
were all when I finally got it up on not
there but at the beginning onto the
Riser all the cameras were blocked so
you can hear on the headsets of the
cameraman from the what the [ __ ] is that
because now it's chaos that's chaos and
they're shooting down the cameras are
good what what
my phone said something it said it's
having trouble hearing me why does my
iPhone have to hear you're with me all
day I'll tell you later everything that
I said yeah anyway so uh and they're
going crazy and everything it took an
eternity I'm sweating Ed is sweating doc
Severance in a sweating and then I
finally got it in and I probably spent
four minutes of what was going to be a
six minute segment oh my God and it's
blocked and I finally sit down and I'm
sweating there and you could tell just
by look at the body language of Johnny
does he look thrilled no no he's it's
just been an eternity of nothing and
then he he's tapping his pencil and he
goes and then I just sat down I didn't
say anything and he's tapping his pencil
and he goes
okay
okay
he goes
what
what is this
and I go please Johnny
I don't want to talk about this
he goes
really I said I'll talk about anything
else nice something that's really
personal to me and I don't want to talk
and then he asked me I could see he was
mad and he gave me like a look he asked
me like one or two questions and I I
realized like I'm in trouble yeah so I
answered those questions he said we'll
be back right after this now I'm
supposed to do two segments oh no he
didn't say a word to me the next I I
can't remember who it was Connie Stevens
or whatever ladies and gentlemen Connie
Stevens they took that away and they
moved me down the couch and I got a call
from Jim saying he never wants you on
the show again oh wow and that was my
last time on the show
wow is that a happy ending good run
though 22 22. it's a great ride good run
it's a good way to end too it's a good
way to end kind of poetic actually it's
really the only way you know I got
thrown off at the Lettermen show too
15 years wow but he had me back
eventually when he was on CBS at the Ed
Sullivan but when he was on NBC late
night yeah I always like that that's why
I love you your kind of Comedy I went to
New York and I was on Letterman yeah and
I sat down and I said it's great being
here in New York I have so many friends
here can I say hi to one of my friends
yeah and he said yeah so I left
hahaha
I went to say hi oh really that's funny
never came back you know out of the I've
been 50 years old I've never been on any
of those shows which one I did Jay Leno
one time yeah it's the only talk show
I've ever done have you pursued it no I
I'm not gonna pursue what they call well
the difference is no nobody calls you in
life whatever is in your mind you just
do it just the Nike has the best
philosophy just do it if you want to do
that then you should have your
agents call and say you have if that's
something you want to do I don't think
it has the same weight it doesn't it
doesn't so it doesn't really matter and
I think talk shows are kind of very 80s
now even when you watch them they don't
mean anything unless you want to do so I
think I when I did Jay Leno right I he
called me over the couch I had a great
couch segment
and then I remember the next day waking
up and no one called
no one's ever mentioned it ever but you
just did I know I just did but no but in
terms of like no